no way you don't play louis c.k in a bio
yeah that's gonna be me I'm gonna play
Louie I'm really Louie but you know what
uh we talked about this before a little
bit I was mad I had to I had to get on
Instagram this morning and talk about
because I was mad and all this [ __ ]
about Louie I think it's [ __ ] I'm
being serious now for a minute I think
it's so annoying you can't record people
in comedy [ __ ] clubs yeah and this is
not about me people got mad at me when I
talked about it one time and they were
like oh were you supporting Louie I'm
like you're missing the point
yeah I am a stand-up comic is gonna be
my whole life I don't want people have
the ability to record me when I don't
want it out there yeah dude that's
[ __ ] I don't want that [ __ ] out in
the world it's not ready if I put it
online myself and you're like [ __ ] you
and want to criticize it fine I put it
out there you can't do that when I'm
working on [ __ ] yeah and I said this
I've said this about ten times I think I
said it over on on a [ __ ] in doofuses
podcast I said to them Shark Tank what
is it podcast what I'll get fight fire
in the in the child yeah I think what I
have a kid in the name that's [ __ ]
gross
very illegal it's not gonna help him in
court he'll be yours yeah you had a
podcast called fighter and a child is it
okay you're you're going to present yeah
and the one guy's low on plasma you get
that email yeah ryan asking people for
[ __ ] he's bad guy begging he goes can
I come talk to you for a minute about
some opportunities I have for you yeah
it's like a pyramid scheme for plasma
yeah dude
no so late let's blow I got mad at the
recording [ __ ] and I don't really give a
[ __ ] about Luiza
he can do whatever he wants but I said
this before if the if the Westboro
Baptist Church can protest a soldier's
funeral and if the Westboro Baptist
Church can protest the funerals of cops
or service people because they have the
right to then Louie CK has the right to
go perform in a room for people who pay
for it yeah end of story
it's America dude people that go he
should never be allowed to perform again
what are you even talking about yeah
this is not that country bro this is
this is a Europe if people want to pay
tickets to go see his ass they should be
able to go see him this you ever go to
see him and him story that's it that's
just how it goes and if you don't want
like him if you don't like him you don't
want to see it don't hear it don't
support him support Theo support me go
see comics you like and I'll say this is
about Louis man I've only seen I've
maybe I met Louie once I met him met him
a few times when he was coming around
the store
yeah I was selling out the main room I
was on his shows
two or three times Adam will you ever
interact with him ever
we just said hello and he chatted a
minute I mean he probably wouldn't know
me from a [ __ ] home right same same
exact but it's but it's but but still I
don't have an opinion about him as a man
I don't know him right you know
understand when someone goes what do you
think about this person we love two
people love to go I feel this way you're
like do you know him you know I don't
really know him yeah I don't really feel
no I don't really know him I got a vibe
from he just seemed like kind of this
was at that climax he you know he kind
of had like a holier-than-thou type of
vibe that's what you felt when you but I
also have no idea like the pressures you
know if people were constantly coming
I'm sure yeah this was when he was you
know this was two years ago when he was
on the [ __ ] tip-top the only one up
there really yeah he was so low I mean
cuz Chappelle had what was slowly poking
his head back around the store you
remember he would like come into town
and do one night and then ghost and then
never see him again
who Chappelle yeah I feel like he would
come in and then I would not see him
again right he was even in town you know
he's everywhere now he's now he's
hanging around but so loose so I that's
all I remember is that he just but he
that's when he was doing a new hour
every year and it was like a thing you
know you're excited he was on fire this
is how funny it is when people
capitalize on [ __ ] people have been
putting up sets of Louie that aren't
from that night what are like whatever
sets because they want hits and views so
so I said this on the [ __ ] on my
Instagram if you hate him so much why
are you supporting it then yeah because
all you're doing is creating more for
him you're creating more [ __ ] for him to
like to get revenue around his name
right well he can also lay claims to all
of those he can hold the revenue all
from all those channels in one person
for himself that's one thing you may not
know about YouTube like say if there's
like even a segment of this podcast has
somebody clips and uses in some like
montage source I think we can lay a
claim to rev share revenue from that
that other video that somebody should be
able to that's your credit sure that's
your content but now what about this so
so but he got up he joked about the
parklands survive he joked about
parklands shooting did you get my text
he said play that play that that because
that this literally this is only two
minutes it'll say it's it's the exact
things that people are mad about because
there was some other [ __ ] that made his
way on the internet but these two thing
these two jokes he got mad they got mad
about was the
the insensitivity the parklands shooting
and pro pronouns how people want to be
addressed he hit he heard them third
that this this is probably the best
audio disappointed in the younger
generation honestly because I'm 51 years
old and when I was like 18 to my 20s I
mean we were idiots we're getting high
doing mushrooms and [ __ ] and then older
people were like you gotta get your [ __ ]
together we're like you excited to be in
my 50s and see people in their 20s and
be like they're crazy
these kids are young you should be crazy
you should be unhinged not in a suit
saying I'm here to tell you that's not
interesting because you went to a high
school where kids got shots why does
that mean I have a listen to you get
shot you push some fat kids away
but the point of all that [ __ ] is all
comics feel the same way whether or not
you you don't like you like louis c.k or
not nobody wants to be filmed yeah
nobody wants me film unless I want to be
[ __ ] filmed right but that's the
other thing they're itching for people
to get met people want to get triggered
so [ __ ] bad the Tiffany Haddish thing
to me is hilarious yeah people are like
you they want to make news out of
nothing right young people bomb on New
Year's we've all done new your shows you
know how many times I've seen crowds get
so crazy the comic can't perform because
you're there they're shit-faced out of
their [ __ ] mind yelling in the middle
of your set up yeah so so oh I raise
money one time I was gonna piss into a
speaker one time in Louisville on stage
yes if I got a hundred bucks man I was
gonna end my whole career I could have
been electrocuted but thank God I only
got about 70 bucks and this before go
fund me this back means had to ask
everybody in the room that was you know
yeah that was just room [ __ ] yeah
anybody give me money but I think like
the Louis thing is interesting because
it's like yet it's not fair to film
people and hookahs Judd Apatow came out
and slamming and people were talking
about hit him hard yeah but you know
what but you know what it is no we we
our stance is different our stance says
I don't want anybody to film me people
these people that are mad at Louis are
still mad about what he did right I like
that's the point to be what I'm saying
they think that what we're doing is
defending who he is in his actions I'm
just defending the fact that you can't
record a comic when they're working on
[ __ ] right you need to get over the fact
that he's gonna perform Nick can we see
that
mhm yeah Judd came after him on Twitter
okay
this hacky unfunny shallow routine is
just a symptom of how people are afraid
to feel empathy it's much easier to
laugh at our most vulnerable than to
look at their pain directly and show
them and love and concern yeah that he's
all angry so I guess he's saying what
Apatow is saying that it's easier
instead of like approach in the Park
Lane thing with apathy and concern yeah
and empathy it's that what Louie's doing
is I guess maybe going after like
low-hanging fruit I don't I didn't see
it that way at all I saw it as he's just
joking about something that's a really
serious thing which is what every comic
is doing and good comics do use worse
you know are you gonna say
or a comic like him does it's same thing
that Chris Rock does I mean I was there
when Chris Rock told a joke you know
about the the Boston bombing at the
marathon oh yeah yeah and it's a great
joke like it doesn't mean that the
Boston bombing is funny right and I
don't think that that's what this is
I mean Judd F initely I don't know why
he's doing after him though that's
that's the biggest thing I don't write
comic school like why do you care but
your shot also gets grandfathered in as
a comedian if you look at Sam tripley's
can you bring up that tweet I stand with
louis c.k Judd you did you call out Lena
Dunham when she admitted to molesting
her sister or falsely accusing a man of
sexual assault in college no of course
not
if anyone knows hacky it's you
exclamation point you used a cheat code
to get on stage to be one of us we won't
forget this that was Sam Tripoli - said
that yeah
and I remember whenever Judd was touring
with like Schumer that she would always
make fun of like how just not funny he
was good yeah I'm just like and Judds
gonna be there yeah here's my here's my
thing about the whole judd thing but i
didn't understand i saw that yesterday
too
i had why are people why are comics
trying to burn their own right that's
what i understand why would you do that
like it's not i think it doesn't give
him anything right but i think it's part
of its it shows a little bit that he's
not as in the comic cloth as a you know
like or maybe he just wants to keep a
stance with with his viewership of
staying in line with who he's always
been to them that's more what it is to
me it's more like bro if you've spent
your whole career and this isn't about
judd i'm saying if somebody spends their
entire career with an image to uphold
and write who they are to their fans
they have to go that route and not
deviate because they've committed to a
thing but why even go in there why even
have to say anything odd i agree but you
look at how many comics don't say
anything that's the biggest thing to me
it's like look at how many cat look how
many huge comics like the biggest
selling comics in the world right Chris
Rock said nothing Chappelle hasn't said
anything yet Brian Regan you know right
Sebastian you're looking at the top
selling comedians in the world the
highest grossing comics they stay quiet
yeah because they know better cuz like
what what what what is it gonna earn me
right what's gonna earn me to talk [ __ ]
right about you know what I'm saying and
maybe it's just some yeah maybe some of
it's just like a novice
moved by you know of Judea but that made
me wonder I don't know Judd you know
like I know him a little bit I know I
don't around the store and seems like I
know him a little bit uh and he hit him
and I are on great terms he's always
been a cool dude to me yes here I like
Josh I just don't know why he goes after
somewhere like that because it just said
you don't need to yeah just don't need
that [ __ ] like all that does is invite
first of all it's it's it's pandering of
people that are already upset and then
it's inviting enemies right inviting
[ __ ] haters yeah like I spend my
entire [ __ ] career trying to push
away hater [ __ ] yeah all I want to
do is all I want to do is be with people
that are [ __ ] into our fun into
having a good time yeah but that invites
haters joy babies all you're doing is
inviting haters to go come on in say
some foul ass [ __ ] about me yeah it's
tone you don't need that [ __ ] do you
think I'm wonderful part of it was feels
like for some you know if there's some
publicity thing or something like if
he's you know like you never know what
the next foot is gonna be if there's I
think Judd is aligned with a group of
people who are Kentucky condemning louis
c.k right I think he's just a part of a
group of people that are that are doing
that and do you think that it went
because you know do you think it went so
deep that Louie like just said like I
just wonder if he was such an a-hole to
people or if he did other things like
behind the scenes that we don't know yet
made like people that are bigger
fixtures in the stores angry now yeah
I've heard stories that that Louie has
has made a lot of enemies I've heard
these stories yeah but again I don't
know him like that so I'm not going to
go out of my way to [ __ ] start [ __ ] I
don't know that [ __ ] so people
could be like yeah you weren't around
Santino do you you guys weren't around
you weren't you guys weren't around he
was a piece of [ __ ] to me it's like okay
then that's on you but do you feel like
at this point in your career as
successful as some of those people are
yeah you need to [ __ ] on him let me tell
you something right in our come up
generation of comics and our in our
group you know that are growing and
growing fan bases in 10 years when
you're on top of the world if you find
out someone in our group did some [ __ ]
up [ __ ] like that would you waste your
time gain after gaining all that success
and fans would you waste your time
[ __ ] on a guy that used to know
no he was a piece of [ __ ] right no I
don't think I would unless that now
that's what makes me think there must
have been some something happened
between them sure that's what I think
but let me tell you something even if
let's just say we find out in 10 years
that Shaab has been you know selling
kids online yeah cuz that could be that
could be a hand then wearing a lot of
their clothes in the studio so let's
just say we find out some [ __ ] up [ __ ]
about Chang Shan you and stuff like that
I could see I mean I would hate to see
that but I could imagine it it's very
possible I'll let my mind go there
continue I TMZ hits us up in the parking
lot Co What's Up G do you hear about
shop dude congratulations on your world
tour of all your arenas and [ __ ] by the
way you're [ __ ] killing it Theo I
know you're doing your thing but did you
hear about chop did you do you know what
happen to Brendan yeah you know I heard
about it and uh kids dude he was selling
kids online what do we have to say about
that
you know um it I wish him well
that's it I wish him well that's great
I don't need to take time to [ __ ] on
shop yeah and even if Saab was a piece
of [ __ ] to me on the way up I still
won't write I would just be happy I
would be like oh dude well that guy got
what he deserves and I'll just sit in my
good place where I am doing my thing you
think there hasn't been people that have
been shitty to me on the way up oh yeah
and and some of the people that have
treated me like [ __ ]
over the years I see them kind of
slipping and not doing well yeah I just
get to sit back and see that yeah I
don't have to [ __ ] parade around the
internet being like you know who [ __ ]
is eating it right now
no I'll just go amen I'm gonna keep
doing my thing yeah I'll keep going up
yeah it doesn't help man but now do you
think that Louis responds to this do you
think I'll know he he can't win he can't
win right in the same way when he wrote
the apology letter
people said it wasn't good enough I
didn't say the right things he didn't
apologize the right way and and they
might be right by the way and they might
be right their opinion is is I thought
it seemed like the apology letter it was
I mean he's an artful communicator you
know that's one thing people feel like
he didn't say I'm sorry I think whatever
it was I don't really remember right
yeah but what the point is he can't win
right he can't [ __ ] win if he
responds to this can't win you can't win
cannot win no matter what if he says
people shouldn't record my sets
do you don't find some [ __ ] about that
if he goes on tour in a year around
America does he sell ago sellout sellout
sellout so he will he'll sell out so
[ __ ] much it it will only anger
people that hate him more that they
might go see his ass right but do you
then think so do you think that this is
the industry that is hating him or do
you think that this is just industry
dude you know America yeah um America
America Donald Trump America what are we
even talking about this is the inside
baseball industry left this elitist
liberal coastal people going punished
punished punished punished punished
punished and they and and they don't
look inward a lot of people that are
throwing stones at him have a lot of
Secrets yeah and it's probably a lot of
the people knew like a lot of this I
don't know you go ask somebody where I
come from in Chicago in the Midwest yeah
when I go talk to people back home about
[ __ ] when I go hey man what do you guys
feel about Louie a lot of people go yeah
the guy's [ __ ] up what he did that's
[ __ ] up my go I agree that just [ __ ]
up [ __ ] what he did to those girls those
people and they and I said do you think
he should be banished from performing
there like no that's correct I mean
that's crazy yeah that people want him
to still perform the country will still
support him yeah
the business can slash you down you know
do you do you think he um do you think
he towards again I think he does 100 I
think that's what he's doing right now I
think that whole set was a setup I think
that whole set he didn't plan it but I
think it was a setup for him to go if I
think he consciously went if this gets
out it's only gonna set me up to get an
audience to it'll it will it'll be a
line in the sand of either you're gonna
support him from here on out no you're
not and I and I guarantee you if you go
on the [ __ ] Internet there's a lot of
people going this is great I want him to
come back what [ __ ] I saw it on the
thing
I saw it on the Twitter on the original
Twitter audio I saw a million comments
my boy he's back I can't wait to see him
again people like him yeah but just the
business isn't its own head you know up
is this the business of Hollywood is
like a little boy in a room with all of
his toys and if like he stubs a toe on a
toy he's like bring his toy and he
throws it outside of the room and then
he still gets to play with the little
toys that he likes he's a little brat
the business is a little brat it's a
little bratty [ __ ] kid but I can't
imagine that the business can't see that
he could make so much money for them
like they will but but the people that
will operate with him will be will be on
the low right
yeah people that people that operate
with Louis the Booker's the promoters
they have to be on the low if they're
here and if they're not here then they
can be loud do you he could be you know
what he could do for real if he wanted
to [ __ ] walk straight into the fire
he should just align himself with a more
righteous sensibility and be like [ __ ]
it I'll be the comic for Fox News yeah
like [ __ ] it if he really wanted to do
it if he wanted to just say [ __ ] it to
LA in to New York yeah you could just
walk right out into the middle of the
country and sell out forever
yeah dude there's guys selling out that
we don't even talk about anymore that
still sell out around the country that
we don't even know where they are what
they're doing you know just touring the
country selling [ __ ] out yeah we just
get to see this you know
yeah I'm just curious because I feel
like the thing about a guy with a guy
like Louie is once you get to that level
of ego and have that much influence and
that much power
that's populated yeah right I mean when
you're coming in front of people and run
and pastime and jerking off I mean
everybody come it's hard to do that but
that's a [ __ ] power move that is
power he's just trying Hey look at these
socks and then they see you're naked and
they look at the socks first then they
see you're naked and then you come do
you remember that game that boys would
play where they'd be like yo what time
is it and they'd wrap their nuts on
their watch it like that yeah that was
pretty preeminent for Louie you think he
was doing that when he was young oh I
got some gum and you know what does that
gum yeah yeah and it's always one kid
who looked at it for too long yeah so
you're like oh look at this piece of gum
and everyone's like oh and there's one
who's like oh is it great do you but do
I'm just with that much ego I don't feel
like Louie gives up like there's gonna
be that thing where he just Kimble
continues he'll never stop do you think
he'll start the tour and put in parkland
like in that town in parkland Florida
I think he'll start with that me crazy
and sell it out Arena in parkland yeah
yeah you know what I think you know what
I think he will do for real what I think
he'll start he'll do a world tour I
think you'll leave the states oh yeah
because I think there's people that
overseas that want to see him more than
you think yeah that are like come here
come here and do it oh yeah in Saudi
Arabia dude jerking off in front of a
group of women that's it that's like the
let's make a deal over there you get a
tax break for doing yeah yeah yeah I
mean it's crazy you know yeah for real
it's so funny how we're like we have to
say you know like every it's sometimes
it's funny in America how it's like
everybody's welcome here you know
but we have to have but then at the same
time those same people will be like
slamming the way that we behave in this
country yeah but then also the people
that they are totally just willy-nilly
uh willing to let in behave the way that
we behave mm-hmm that they hate exactly
but just because they're from somewhere
else they can come in oh you're a
murderer from [ __ ] you know slack
Adachi come on it's like a yes yeah we
need guys like you
we need more slack a document way that
is something we should talk about we
just have all these old white murderers
and black murderers tired of old white
murder yeah man it's getting really old
this Louie thing man it's it's got in
your head huh well yes it's interesting
I'm just like and then I'm like you know
it's um and then a lot of people would
yeah it's like people would be afraid to
say anything about Apatow cuz people
would be worried about their space in
the industry you know well yeah but that
but I said my two cents on John I like
John I said we're cool John and I are
cool Pete judge always anytime where him
and I talked about doing a podcast you
know him coming on the podcast and stuff
so yeah he goes on a lot of people's
podcasts I like Judd yeah I said that
before I'm not I didn't slander of Judd
I don't know why Judd or anybody wants
to take shots at Louis that's my point
right I'm not taking shots at Judd I
don't [ __ ] I'm not on that right I'm
saying I don't know why people feel like
they need to woody but also do you feel
like you feel like we need to there's
something oh I agree it's unless you've
got like you said if Judd and Louie have
some old beef well then maybe that makes
more sense
but there's comics there's a few comics
that I have heavy heavy beef with that I
do not like as people yeah but let me
tell you something if they go down in a
blaze of fire I am gonna say [ __ ] I
might say to you as my friend right off
the record when I'm not about to tweet
about him good evening good afternoon
and other times thanks for watching that
video you just saw I mean it was okay
but the next video you can watch could
be way better what if you watch a video
right now that changes your life well
you could watch this one or watch this
one watch this one watch this one
watches one